Hello?
Is anyone there?
I'm trying to reach...
I repeat *static* is anyone out there?
*Godzilla growl*
Senators, we believe that these..
"Titans", are just the tip of the iceberg.
*Godzilla growls*
*Godzilla roars*
Which of these titans are here to protect us?
*Godzilla snarls*
*Mothra sings*
*Rodan screams*
And which of these titans are here to threaten us.
*King Ghidorah growls and stirs*
So you'd want to make Godzilla our pet?
*Laughter among the senators*
No. We would be his.
You sure he's gonna be ok?
*Godzilla snarls*
They're everywhere
Battling for dominance
A rival alpha to Godzilla
You gotta be kiddin'
*King Ghidorah shrieks. Mothra sings*
*Godzilla growls*
*King Ghidorah snarls*
Oh sh--
*GODZILLA BELLOWS*
*KING GHIDORAH ROARS*